[Music]
Russia is once again tonight being
accused of interfering in American
domestic affairs this time it's the
national conversation over gun control
sparked by last week's school shooting
in Florida Fox News media analyst and
host of Fox's media buzz Howard Kurtz
tells us how the Russians are trying to
turn the tragedy to their advantage it
was just an hour after the Florida
school shooting that Twitter erupted
with such hashtags as gun control now
gun reform now ar-15 and parkland
shooting and we now know that hundreds
of such posts came from Twitter account
suspected of having links to Russia in
fact the New York Times reports today
this Russian social media blitz is part
of a far-reaching disinformation
campaign that includes conspiracy videos
on YouTube phony interest groups on
Facebook and so-called BOTS that can
drive a Twitter discussion and push it
into the mainstream media analysts say a
divisive subject like gun control is
fertile ground for these covert Russian
operatives whose goal is to fueled
conflict and frustration in America what
they're trying to do is foment
dissension and anger they're really
trying to get Americans to point fingers
at one another to drive wedges and
double down on fissures that exist in
our society special counsel robert
muller highlighted the problem last week
with indictments against 13 russians for
cyber hacking and trying to disrupt the
presidential campaign
these russians are alleged to have
covertly organized political rallies in
the u.s. days after the election Muller
charges they coordinated one New York
rally quote to show your support for
president elect Trump's and another
called Trump is not my president in the
case of protesting NFL players the
Russians took their cue from the
president's criticism by pushing such
hashtags as boycott NFL and stand for
our anthem as well as take a knee after
the Russian BOTS whipped up gun control
sentiment in the wake of the Florida
shooting they moved on to the hashtag
false flag pushing an outlandish
conspiracy theory that students had
rehearsed their actions in advance and
the tragedy never happened a year of
heavy media coverage fostered the
impression that Russian hackers were
mainly interested in putting Donald
Trump in the White House it's now clear
the
Russian propaganda and disinformation
are a constant fact of life even or
perhaps especially when Americans are
being killed Brett how are you thanks